accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to the executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and
selective legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
the contemporaries
listening and if necessary participate
in a meeting by the zoom platform by
tour by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting shall call 271
3600 or email hcs at
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
assess the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all the votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
so let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance with each member
states that presence please also state
whether there's anyone in the room
with you during the meeting which is
required under the right to know law
okay you're on keith can you hear us
from the committee room
i can hear you yes okay
so that that's you and jason yeah
you were good too both ways there are
good
good mics in that those committee rooms
calling the role uh
representative yes i am here and i am
alone
representative yeah i'm here
alone upstairs in my house my wife's
downstairs
representative osborne here in the
committee room
representative admin here in the
representative abramson i'm i'm here i'm
present
representatives
[Music]
representative
yeah your microphone is a little messy
there
[Music]
here and alone representative
herbert here and alone
representative van outen president alone
representative fargo i'm here and i'm
alone
representative wesson here and alone
representative bellew here home alone
representative girls
here alone representative
here alone okay that's 19 presents
sure that's wonderful
everybody's here all right um
i just want i i got a couple of calls
uh so this is speaking to the people who
are attendees or listening in
got a couple of calls and people were
trying to sign up or trying to get in
uh this is an exact session so there is
no particular reason why we would ever
invite anybody
to uh speak to us because theoretically
uh we're
we're going to be in the voting mode so
we're not really
taking any hearings but
uh having said that so don't any of you
try to raise your hand unless you have a
really
burning problem
so otherwise we'll begin
and first up is senate bill 14.
uh this is relative to the direct
shipping of liquor
and i will make the motion of ought to
pass and representative patusek will
second my motion
and this is the bill that is for the
liquor commission
so that they can be in the direct
shipping business and i
don't believe there's anybody that's in
anybody else like to speak
in moshe's all to pass to pass
okay um representative
yes representative osmond
yes representative yes representative
amos
so you're muted yes
representative palmer yes representative
griezmann
yes representative johnson
yes representative paul oh terry
excuse me yes representative
yes representative abel
yes representative herbert
yes representative van gaal yes
president fargo yes representative
weston
yes representative bellew
yes representative burroughs
yes
yes representative yes
that's 19-0 all right voters 9-0 all
those in favor of placing uh
senate bill 14 on the consent calendar
okay content all right
senate bill 17 brew pub
and dogs and nano contract brewers
uh representative patusek
seconded by representative hun moves to
retain
senate bill 17. and representative
patuseki you can speak to your motion
uh okay uh the the
group of dogs part of this is very
kind of contentious there's a lot of
health laws
that are involved with
that part of it and
service dogs versus companion dogs
so it still needs a lot of work in that
piece
and the nano contract brewers piece of
it is
already being addressed in sb 125
so i move that we retain it to work
on especially the dogs part of it
okay uh we do have conversation
uh so uh see whose hands up who's up
first representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chair um
i'm gonna vote against retain i really
feel this
is an ipl um that there's um
as representative patuck says there's an
awful lot to be done on this
the second part of it is being covered
under um senate bill 125 with all the
work that was done on that and
i don't see where this can be um
salvaged
so i'm going to vote against retention
with i'm hoping that a
motion to itl will go forward
okay and representative weston
i agree with christie um i think there
were a number of people that were
uncomfortable with the with
melding the dog situation in with
everything else about the nanobrewery
and rather than spending our time
on this why not just let it itl
and we've got the other part of the of
the bill
in 125 anyway so i don't with all the
bills we have retained i don't think we
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain
uh seeing none the clerk will call the
roll
two sec two two second hunt move to
retain
okay representative yes
representative possible yes
representative hammond yes
hi representative
yes yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett no representative
herbert
no
representative van gaal no
representative fargo no representative
wesson
no representative
value no representative burroughs
no representative back leader
yes
okay uh next up
senate bill 18 uh liquor at farmer's
market uh representative petusik is
moves
out to pass and representative hunt
seconds the motion
is there any discussion on the motion of
uh to pass um yes
i believe we have an amendment that was
distributed by
um ms sparling
just for grammar and it should have been
yes yes i i did
and it was it was um filed by
representative van houten
right so the
purpose of it is simply grammar
that's probably important for something
i'll speak to that for just a quick
moment
i think it was just a convoluted wording
there and um i don't believe i changed
the intent whatsoever i ran it by
representative weston who also had
concerns about the grammar
uh for her her kind of look-see with it
and i assume that everyone has had a
chance since yesterday to look at it i
do believe i preserved the intent
totally
just made it a little bit clearer as to
what the intent is
uh you'll find the wording i retained
most of the words i simply put them into
did you run it by the liquor commission
i did not
i i did in in the hearing i did bring it
up in the hearing
right now i remember you saying you're
uncomfortable
okay well i did talk to aiden and uh
he says it does seem to be just
reshuffling the chairs
with the paragraph so it's not totally
uh in uh offensive um
he said uh he did say it might be
helpful
in the sense that it clarifies the issue
of selling
versus giving it away which is um
stated in another part of the section so
that he did not
particularly find anything wrong with
this pair of
so i guess i would say is that assuming
we pass this amendment you're
you guys you'll be in support of the
bill
[Music]
okay okay so um uh
representative would you uh uh
withdraw your motion for ought to pass
and and
be willing to withdraw your motion and
so that we can take up another motion
emotion is withdrawn okay
so uh representative uh so
who's who's making this motion is going
to be van houghton
seconded by representative hunt uh moves
out to pass on the amendment and what's
the amendment number
all right is the question clear
uh this is on the amendment uh the clerk
can call the role
all right just uh catching up um so that
was
van halen and seconded by hunts sure yes
it's amendment 1403.
just once okay
mr chairman yes uh
for the record um if it's not too
onerous could we
just have the the amendment or the
language the change read into the record
uh i mean is it is it a sentence what
what are we talking about here
it is it is a sentence well actually i
think the whole paragraph yeah it's a
sentence
um did did you not get a copy of it uh
no
but it what what was changed in the
sentence a comma or a word
uh it it was uh the sentence uh was
kind of uh reshuffled it was just the
word order was rearranged
correct with no with with no
change no change in policy all right
fine thank you
i'm ready to call rule okay uh
the clerk will call the role on
amendment 1403
yes representative
uh yes representative osborne
okay yes representative yes
representative
hi representative
yes representative palmer
yes representative greeson yes
johnson yes representative terry
yes instead of bartlett yes
sort of people yes representative
herbert
yes okay representative fargo
yes representative weston yes
representative bellew yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclean
yes representative hunts
yes he's 19-0 okay
motion is accepted uh representative two
sec seconded by representative van
houden moves out to pass as amended
is there any discussion on the motion
representative yes
representative osborne yes
representative m and yes representative
abramson
hi representative yes
representative palmer yes representative
greeson yes representative johnson
yes representative terry
representative yes
sorry president of herbert yes
representative yes representative fargo
yes representative wesson yes
representative value yes representative
burroughs
yes representative yes
representative fonts yes that's 19-0
false pastors all those in favor of
placing senate bill 18 on the consent
calendar please say
aye aye i was opposed
a question from the clerk on a previous
bill
yeah senate bill 17 uh
did we discuss the minority report oh
that's right
uh the retain it it's a retaining motion
so it will not be debated on the floor
okay uh senate bill 35 relative to
membership and risk pools
representative johnson second by
representative patusek moves
in expedient to legislate representative
johnson is recognized to speak to a
motion
hi so um i
recommend uh in experience to legislate
because this is setting a bad precedence
um for future lobbyists trying to
uh really obtain coverage for
the organization they're working with it
just it sets a bad precedence i think
all the way around
okay uh representative bartlett
i have to say that i'm um vehemently
opposed to this motion
um i think that there's no reason at all
why um the employees
of the nea um shouldn't be able to join
the risk pool it
was set up um as such that there were
absolutely no objections to it um and i
do feel that
um they should be able to get into a
risk pool
there's there's no cost to the taxpayer
there's no
um drawback um to allowing them to be
um thank you i absolutely agree with
representative bartlett and as i look
back through
some of the information that was
provided to us uh this passed the senate
24-0 it passed in committee five to zero
secretary of state um has endorsed this
this is not a political statement by any
stretch of the imagination
it's simply providing an avenue into
something that
should have already been done in the
past it was it should have been done
when these risk pools were established
and i think that we'd be doing a great
disservice to carve people out simply
because they are
part of another group um there are many
organizations that come to us whether
they be lobbyists or or
volunteer organizations that have vested
interest in things because there would
be some benefit to them
that doesn't exclude them from
participation
in in something that is rightfully
theirs and therefore i will be voting
against this motion as well
uh in order to preserve something that
is appropriate for employees
uh that that they should be having and
should have had from the very beginning
thank you yeah i i would
uh point out representative bartlett
risk pools are tax-free
uh so they don't pay the insurance tax
so there is some consideration that it
does affect the taxpayers and
the issue of um and potential adverse
election we don't know
obviously we can't make a judgment on
that but it does seem
like a precedent that we probably should
not go down
any other comments uh from the committee
seeing none the clerk will call the role
please repeat okay so the motion is uh
inexpedient to legislate
on symbol 35 representative johnson
second by representative patusik
okay call the roll uh representative
yes representative osborne yes
representative
yes representative abramson aye
representative ham
yes representative palmer yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative department no
representative
abel
yes yes yes no i mean no
i mean thank you i'm sure now
representative herbert no
what's under van halen muted
no
the space bar is kind of i'm sorry no it
doesn't always work
for me it only works if you have zoom as
the focused window
you know what i mean if you're on
another program that it won't work
um representative no
representative weston uh yeah my space
bar just didn't work but uh
no representative bill you
no representative burroughs
no representative mcaleer no
representative hans uh yes
uh yes kate robertson uh
promotion is ten to nine almost
bipartisan uh
but it could have been right okay
uh motions pen ten to nine uh will there
be
a minority report yes
okay the minority motion is also passed
and the
and that's uh was that representative
van halton will be the
yeah um honey do you want to do that i
i'm sorry
i didn't catch that you're muted yes you
want to do the minority report good yes
representative
okay uh senate bill 36
residency under the auto insurance
policies
uh representative bartlett has an
amendment for this
yes i do um it was distributed to
everybody
um and what it did was
take out the um wording
um at that time and i did run this
through um past
james fox at the insurance department
and he just changed
it to i haven't got it right here um
at issuance or renewal um and they were
fine with that we we felt that there was
a little bit of them
ambiguity on at this time on the
original bill
three zero three thank you one
so i'm sorry to catch it one three two
three zero three
okay uh so the emotion uh and um
representative hunt will second the
motion
so uh representative uh is there any
questions on
representative bartlett's amendment um i
do have one
okay representative um and uh mr chair
maybe you can answer this
what was the original intent behind the
uh the sponsors of the bill what were
they trying to uh
change uh well which is not
really related to i guess some related
to the amendment but um
the issue is that right now um we have a
statute
that requires that when you get a new
auto insurance policy you have to stick
that you're a resident of new hampshire
and it was originally intended to
ensure that people from other states
weren't trying to
register their cars in new hampshire to
get
lower auto insurance rates as it turns
out it was
some it was somewhat problematic getting
people to sign these forms and
paperworks and delays as some of you
might know it can be rather easy to
add another card to your policy it all
it takes is a simple phone call
but for some auto insurance policies uh
it
did require yet another having you
signed that other form again
so insurance agents uh uniformly uh have
said that most media insurance but was
we did see at the last moment there was
some you know insurance agents who
thought it was a good idea to keep it
but the vast majority of them thought it
was a good idea to get rid of it
and that the disparity in auto insurance
um and it was particularly in
massachusetts was the issue
has that disparity has gone since
massachusetts
got rid of their no doubt no fault
policies
um so so um at this point in time it
it's really not necessary and it just it
creates a delay for some consumers and
getting their insurance
all right fair enough any other
discussion on the amendment
see none the clerk will call the roll
just catching up it was made by
representative bartlett second by
the motions not to pass on the amendment
all right calling the role
of representative yes representative
osborne
yes representative admin yes
[Music]
yes terry yes
president of bartlett yes representative
people
yes yes representative herbert
yes representative yes
registered fargo yes representative
weston
yes representative bell you yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer
yes there are fonts yes
i think i just say the t extra long
19 to zero
i'm from pittsburgh i drink i eat heinz
ketchup
okay i'll call you that for mommy but i
okay uh motion passes uh so the motion
now representative bartlett second by
representative hunt moves out to pass
has amended
on senate bill 36 is there any
discussion on the motion about to pass
rule
yes
yes representative
representative i'm sorry
recent yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
representative herbert yes
i'm sorry yes forget about that space
bar
yes representative bellew
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mclean yes
19-0 okay all those in favor of placing
cinnamon
bill 36 on the consent calendar please
say aye
all right and those opposed
so moved unanimously okay
senate bill 38 treatment centers
uh representative uh greece in second by
representative batusik
moves to retain senate bill 38.
and you're recognized to speak to your
motion
yeah so the the
intent of this bill is to uh reduce the
cost to consumers
for the products sold at these
dispensaries
and during the testimony it was brought
up that what's keeping the prices high
is current regulations and so
we thought that if we just retain this
bill
let's evaluate with what's currently in
statute
that maybe whatever the whatever is is
whatever those regulations are maybe we
need to address
that rather than implementing something
new uh that may or may not have the
desired effect so
give this a little bit of time let's
let's see what's on the books now if
there's something we can repeal or
adjust that way
okay uh representative bartlett thanks
very much um
i don't feel we need to retain this i
think we um
we saw this last year we um voted it
through and it was very bipartisan and
it was lost in the covid
um demise and i do think that
um this is affecting the pricing
that those that need medical cannabis
must pay
um that's not covered by insurance in
any way
so if they can get a reduction in the
pricing i think that's really important
for the
10 000 patients that are now using
medical cannabis in new hampshire
so i'm going to vote against retain
because i would like to see
the bill passed okay
representative abel yes i i want to say
i agree with my
uh colleagues from across the aisle
about
regulation in this situation
and i think that this bill we ought to
vote
uh to pass this bill because it removes
what's been identified as the major
regulation
that prevents uh these companies in new
hampshire from
from being able to compete so i would
ask you to reconsider
your uh your um
recommendation on this can i speak to
the motion
uh uh go ahead and put your hand up uh
[Music]
okay representative abramson and then
you can speak
um i i didn't like the retain
motion and the reason that i thought
that the bill should pass is that this
is a bill that's already come through
committee before
um it passed the senate 18 to six but
it's passed this committee before
um or i was told it was passed 18-3 i
wasn't here to see that happen
um it seemed like it was a pretty small
change in and um the the only person we
could find in the past to insist
that these be non-profits was uh
governor john lynch
and that was a compromise made to get
his signature
um on this originally that was about um
10 years ago it's kind of fuzzy in my
mind i can't quite remember
exactly what the whole discussion was at
that time but um
uh when you have one kind of linchpin or
one elected official who
who requires a compromise and that
person is no longer in office then
you know when an election is passed we
can reconsider
those things and and i never heard any
concern from anyone about
need for them to be non-profits
my concern is that they're paying so
much money and interest
rates to borrow money and if
anything that we can do to save
businesses in new hampshire money
i think that we should we should be
doing that so
this came over as a bipartisan bill
there were actually more republicans
sponsors on the bill
um and um it's certainly a republican
platform bill
so i'm going to be supporting the bill i
would normally vote to retain but since
this bill has come through before i'm
representative
thank you mr chair um i'm going to be
voting for retain
but with with this intention in mind
that uh
i agree with allowing for-profit status
but since there's only four licenses and
two of them are owned by the same
company uh
we're going to eventually uh be dragged
into the future
of having a retail market
for cannabis in our state and these
three companies are going to be
poised to enter that retail market
so i think it's important to increase
the number of licenses
at the same time as allowing for-profit
status
so that we set up our future market uh
to have competition and not be dominated
by a few companies that have had
you know an advantage so i'll be voting
to retain
but with that idea in mind of increasing
number of licenses
at the same time there's a lot of
for-profit status for
a revision for next year so
am i can i ask am i off on that
um anticipation that
that we can accomplish that you're
you're entitled to your opinion yeah
absolutely yeah representative i really
urge you to
reconsider this there was no evidence
no evidence at all presented that they
actually paid a dime
of interest when you consider that the
fact of the
that these things are owned by a
for-profit
marijuana business in massachusetts
there is no doubt in my mind
that they're loaning that money with
expectation that eventually it will be
become a for-profit once we legalize
marijuana
and to suddenly change this statute at
this moment
seems to me to be uh inappropriate
uh given when we're clearly if you're
really
thinking about what you're going to do
to make the business uh
you know the the medicine the product
more affordable is to look at all
the myriad of regulations
i mean i hear that they barcode every
plant
and they go around and check in them and
they do that and
and you know there's no doubt in my mind
that they that the whoever is under
underwriting these businesses
is not paying a lot of interest and it's
probably the wrong it's their own cash
uh representative bartley have your hand
the point is that the recreational
marijuana is not legal now and it's not
going to be legal
certainly anytime in the near future
because of the um
sense of the governor so those that are
relying
on the medical cannabis as a better form
of
treatment for their various conditions
that
we know that it there is a beneficial um
aspect to this that they are being
affected now
and we've put this off before
it was passed i wanted you know i i
really think that we need to give some
relief
um to those that are paying these prices
um and this is a way to do it
there are 10 000 patients out there and
this affects them
but there was no evidence demonstrating
that they actually paid a dime in
interest
they never showed us any of their
financials we never saw any of that how
do you know this is true
if i go back to my statement this is
keith
is it possible to increase the number of
licenses
with a retained version of this bill or
do i need to switch my vote and vote for
the bill
we if we if we retain the bill it's free
to
have many anything we want to do to
change it we can change it
they might have to go to another
committee but it would be free to be
changed
representative greeson
thank you mr chairman during the
testimony
it was presented i don't remember who
she was that
that was speaking but even if this bill
were to pass
she was still going to go shopping in
maine it was just still going to be
cheaper wherever she was going to buy it
it didn't sound to me like that those
who are going out of state
uh were actually going to stay in the
state of new hampshire
uh i think most of them are probably
buying the recreational stuff
anyway and not really concerned about
the medical
aspect of it because they're getting
what they consider to be
higher quality better flavors whatever
the variety that are not going to be
available
at the the state stores anyway so
as far as they needing help and trying
to reduce the price
i really don't see where anybody is
going to change their habits as it is
anyway
uh representative abramson is your hand
still up from before or
did you have something else you wanted
to say yeah i wanted to respond to your
uh
remark um we i've said this on the floor
probably
about a dozen times this session we
compete in the
new england market not just in the new
hampshire market so when when people say
well there are only four licenses for
this
or 10 licenses for that in the state or
something as a you know
only one or two operations consumers
live all over new england they shop all
over new england and they work all over
new england
and part of the new hampshire advantage
is that we
for for businesses and independent
contractors
and subcontractors is that we want to
have
as few regulations and as low taxes of
course
but as few regulations and as few
restrictions as humanly possible
um on businesses
to to maintain that that business
friendly environment
but we don't generally i mean the
republican platform says
it as few regulatory restrictions as
possible
and uh we've kind of put this this
question in front of the the delegation
and they've they've said that they put
it into the the platform and that's what
we go to the voters with every year
less government and uh less regulation
um so i'm the the voters approved that
and i i very very rarely find voters who
want more restrictions
on anything so that that's exactly why
we're talking about retaining it is to
is to to reduce restrictions
that are on uh that are in this law
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair um and i think one of the points
that um is being made about
crossing state lines people are still
taking a risk
by doing that and i think that
those that are that need the medical
cannabis
to risk their lives to get a lower price
um
and that's what they're that's what
they're doing when they're crossing
state lines
because it is illegal federally um so i
you know i don't have a problem with
with allowing more licenses that's
that's fine then that could certainly
the the law could be amended
um in the future if we were to pass this
now um
retaining is just going to continue to
delay
um the relief that i believe that
but there's no guarantee that the prices
will actually go down if we pass this
legislation
you're you're you're you're taking
you're taking the word that they're
that that's that's an issue for their
costs but they never actually said
and we promise we will lower our price
well i believe that they did say that
according to my notes
it did say that they would reduce it
that's where increased competition comes
in that that will force them
trust me i i agree with you
representative okay representative
greeson
your hand i accidentally left it up okay
any more discussion on the motion to
retain
senate bill 38 seeing none
uh the clerk will call the roll
representative yes
representative osborne yes
representative yes representative
abramson
representative de palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry
representative abel no representative
herbert
representative mcelroy now
okay representative
bartlett i am glad to make a motion otp
okay remember bartlett who's
up to pass i'll second that
and that was second by representative
see now the clerk will call the oh no
i'm sorry
we probably already said what we had to
representative osmo no
representative yes representative
representative now
representatives of palma no
where is that of greece no
representative johnson
representative abel
yes representative herbert yes
representative fargo yes
representative bellew yes
representative fonts one more time in my
career
no
okay uh i'd be glad you do the monar
the majority report yeah so i got you
down for the majority report
okay uh
the vote uh rep is a good representation
of what the
committee feels okay senate bill 49 new
hampshire trust code
uh representative hunt uh second by
representative matuzik
moves out to pass um this
these were minor little issues that were
left
laying around with the trust code
statute didn't make it through last year
and uh so this the trust code
um i guess i i want to emphasize to
people
that i have never and i have sponsored a
lot of these trust code bills
have never said that this was a
huge potential to create jobs in new
hampshire
i've always said that i'm that
the reason why i sponsor these bills is
i was trying to keep new hampshire
on the forefront of our statutes in
terms of being competitive with other
states
that were seen to be getting the lion's
share of these trust codes
and and there was some economic benefit
to those states for doing it
and so therefore in my mind this bill
these are minor little issues that are
being addressed and
there's no reason why we shouldn't um
make sure that our trust code is
is up-to-date and competitive
representative bartlett thanks very much
um yes i am going to
oops wrong wrong button um
i am going to support this um uh motion
i think that um it makes it easier
for those that are that are doing the
investments and setting up the
the trust to be able to use socially
products and um so i i will be
supporting it
any other discussion on emotion about to
pass
representative representative osborne
yes representative m yes
representative abramson aye
representative ham yes representative de
palma
yes representative johnson yes
representative terry uh yes
representative bartlett yes
representative
abel yes representative herbert
yes representative van gaal yes
represent fargo yes representative
weston
yes representative
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcleod yes
my team zero okay um all those in favor
of placing senate bill 49
on the consent calendar please say aye
aye aye aye
opposed so moved unanimously and that
was
seconded by patusek is that correct yes
yes
okay senate bill 59 collaborative care
model service delivery representative
ammon
seconded by representative patusik moves
in expedient to legislate
representative ammon is recognized to
thank you uh mr chair um i moved in
expedience legislate
um the baseline testimony that we heard
this
bill uh this law isn't necessary this is
more of like an informational
uh piece of legislation rather than
something that
would have an actual impact
the uh insurance companies already have
the codes
to do the referrals um
and so this this isn't there it's my
understanding that there isn't
an issue to be solved that's more of
educating the public
educating consumers that they have this
ability to
request the referral from out of the
network into the network
so i move on to uh i move it expedition
legislate on
representative bartlett thank you very
much um
i have to say that i strongly disagree
with
the itl i think that it's really
important that
consumers understand that they do have
this access
i think the collaborative
model is important between the pcps and
those that are
offering um psychiatric care and i think
that reimbursement is also important
for um this and the insurance companies
were in favor of this
so i don't understand why you would want
to kill
this bill that that clarifies this
access so of course we'll
be opposing the motion
representative burrows yes i i agree
with um
with representative bartlett and it's my
understanding also that this bill
will enable um primary care physicians
to get paid
for collaborating um with a
collaborative care model under this bill
okay well not that i want to pick a
fight with everybody here but
um there's a little some misleading so i
want to make sure everybody understands
exactly what this bill is about
okay um in terms of the idea that this
is a model legislation because often we
use that term model legislation
and model legislation means it's a new
concept
and you're implementing it for you know
you know that other states are
all adopting this and we're in um so
that is uh
can't be further from the truth this is
not a model in terms
of um this is anything new the codes
have always existed
this has always been available to the
primary care physician it's not so much
to the consumer knowing anything about
this
it's really the primary care physician
and that the
fundamental purpose of this legislation
and i think the sponsors will tell you
is to educate primary care physicians
that this statute exists well last time
i checked doctors don't spend a lot of
time reading our rsas
and matter of fact i don't think they
ever read our essays and that the
reality is the only people who do read
the rsas
are the insurance companies who have to
deal with it
um the insurance companies uh have made
it clear to me in no uncertain terms
that it's not that they for it or
against it
or care one way about it um their their
only comment
is it doesn't seem appropriate to be
putting
a procedure that is available
into the statute for no other reason
than other than we're trying to educate
people that it exists as i said to the
medical society when they called me
and i said why aren't you teaching this
in your continuing education courses so
that every primary care physician
knows that this is available to them um
and
he says well that's a good point
insurance companies
um there's some little talk about you
know that they've changed their position
or something like that
no insurance companies um will tell us
that they
are they at the hearing they said they
are in support
of what the senate amendment did because
the original bill
was problematic and they were in support
of the amendment
but that every insurance company will
say to you that whether we pass this or
don't pass it
it doesn't change the fact that this is
already available
and frankly it does somewhat set up an
awkward precedent that you're putting
procedure
processes which already exist into the
statute for no other reason than to
educate
primary care physicians representative
bartlett
there are many times that we have to
clarify practice
and we do it through law we've got 119
in favor
that signed in on this one with one
opposed and one neutral
um i think that says something right
there and i think when harvard pilgrim
comes in dartmouth hitchcock comes in
new futures comes in i mean one after
the other they know that there is a need
for this
um and it will help consumers but it
will also help
the practices so that they can be clear
that when psychiatric care is
called for that they can deliver in a
collaborative world
without a consumer having to go
to another physician to be able to get
the care needed
the bcp really is the one in many cases
that can identify the issues
and being able to have this readily
available
i think is really important
i don't know how putting it in the
statute makes it more readily available
than it already is
but there are lots of things that we do
that that um
that helps i think most of the time the
statutes
especially when it comes to health
insurance there are mandates to say that
so any other discussion on the motion
of uh inexpediting to legislate on
senate bill 59
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative aye
representative osborne yes
representative hammond
yes representative terry
yes representative bartlett
no representative abel no
instead of herbert no representative
no representative fargo no
representative weston no
representative bill you no
representative burroughs
no representative mclean no
yes tend to know
okay uh where there
be a minority report there will be
uh that would be new representative
bartlett and i assume it would be out to
pass
is there anybody else who wants to do
that i'm glad to do it if anybody else
would like to
okay i'm
i'm there okay
uh i think we're close to halfway all
right senate bill 66 on premise
transportation
uh one is for delivery um
i believe i have an amendment uh so i
would like to
move uh ought to pass um on
let me pull it up amendment number 1398
um and represented by two second seconds
my motion
about to pass the
uh purpose of the amendment is simply to
uh remove
the sunset uh clause in senate bill 66
so that
that the restaurants can use the statute
going forward forever until we repeal it
or something
so any other discussion on the amendment
uh to senate bill 66
representative van halen thank you mr
chair
um this calls to mind another bill
fairly recently to which we added a
sunset clause for two years because we
saw that the
uh the pandemic the covid uh situation
had probably been what precipitated it
and therefore two years would probably
be enough time to do that
this is very similar in that sense and
that is probably kova driven pandemic
driven
and yet we're flipping around here i
think uh to
to get into language that i don't
typically will use
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander i think that
that we need to be very very fairly
consistent in what we're doing if we're
going to sunset
um legislation that is very similar
let's be consistent across the board
therefore i feel that this this
amendment is is counter-intuitive to
what it is
that was put in previously when we
talked about the bill of course was the
bill about the um
uh the delivery drivers uh going to
restaurants and picking up
uh meals when they did not have a
contract with them and we
didn't get a two-year sunset on that
that that was argued by
people who are now taking the the
opposite tact and i think we're going in
the wrong direction to be
uh two-faced about what we do thank you
okay why as though
as being the people i will tell you were
absolutely wrong
because the dash doordash grubhub bill
was a mandate of a contract
which is totally anathema to what we
normally would do in this
committee and this bill with this sunset
was a sunset that if the senate
had spent a little more time on it
rather than rushing it through because
it was a bill that was passed
last year and somehow didn't get it get
into effect but they didn't happen
this is a opportunity this is not a
mandate this is not forcing anybody to
do anything
and this is just enabling legislation
and so therefore
uh rip representative polio
yeah um i'm not gonna vote for
um this um the the amendment
um i think alcoholics could
in in the future take advantage of this
bill and i think it should be looked at
again
after you know sunset or you know before
sunset
so i'm not going to you know i'm going
to vote to keep the sunset
fair enough uh represent fargo
um i i'd like to just weigh in as well i
think a sunset here is appropriate
i guess it's time to to study the
effects of this and to determine if it's
uh
encouraging people who should be having
alcohol delivered to their homes um
i'm gonna i can't support the amendment
i think the sunset should be there
as you once told me john in two years we
can take it off if we wanna
that's true that's true
i didn't blame it on alcoholics but in
this case the law is already in effect
uh well actually it's about to expire
with the governor's
uh uh uh instead of emerging about this
fire but
so i don't know does anybody knows we
have more alcoholics now because of this
um i'm just curious is uh are all the
people that
are supposed to enforce the laws still
there
uh the uh in terms of enforcement
division
is still uh that the bill is in the
yes there so the question is open as to
whether or not they're going to have the
no there's they're still there right at
this moment
uh okay connie is your hand up from
before
or are you wondering yes it is thank you
i'd just like to respond to your
statement from earlier
i do understand that there are
differences between the bills and i do
understand that one deals with a
contract and
and the other does not uh however i
think the difference
uh is is not the same as the
similarities the similarities
here are that covet that a pandemic
brought these
issues to the forefront and therefore we
have done things to enable our business
or to help our businesses
to move forward in very dastardly times
i hope
and and expect that in two years a lot
of this will change and as
i believe it was representative uh fargo
said
uh we can look at it again in two years
but right now let's put the sunset on
there so this doesn't fall through the
cracks
let's let it be covered driven let's do
the right thing by businesses by having
by having this type of thing go on but
let's put a sunset on it so that we can
be fair and equitable to all the
businesses
thank you yeah i just wanted to let you
know that the
the doordash gun bill that issue
the lawsuit they won was actually prior
to cobit
so that was a pre pre-coveted issue that
these people were but our vote was a
code edition when we
when we took it up and we voted on it it
was a covet issue
i don't want to argue with you but you
were right you didn't your mind was
becoming an issue
in my mind it was a contractual
arrangement
so okay uh you you're all set
uh your headset okay uh so the motion is
uh ought to pass on the amendment
is there uh any discussion uh on the
i'm just gonna excuse me we're done it's
good to the potion
um it is now ought to pass on the
amendment and the clerk will call the
role
and it's amendment number 1398h
right 98. 98. 1398h
yes representative osborne yes
representative yes representative palmer
yes representative griezmann yes
president johnson yes representative
terry
yes representative bartlett no
representative abel
no representative herbert no
there's an event hounton no
fargo no representative weston
no representative bill you
no was it a burroughs no
okay uh representative uh ham seconded
by representative patusik moves
out to pass as amended is there any
discussion
representative yes representative
osborne
is representative yes representative
abramson
aye representative yes
representative de palma yes
greeson yes so johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes
no representative van outen
reluctantly yes representative fargo
yes representative weston yes
representative bill you no
representative burroughs yes
representative mcleary yes
representative hans yes
17 to 2.
so uh the two who
voted against it uh you are you have a
problem with
putting this on the consent calendar no
no no okay all those in favor please say
uh putting uh uh senate bill 66 on the
consent calendar and say aye
those supposed to move unanimously
okay
all right senate bill
68 representative johnson second by
representing
too sick moves to retain and
uh representative johnson is recognized
ah i'm looking to retain um so that we
can collaborate
and to make this more appropriate for
everybody concerned and
okay uh representative abramson your
have your hand up first yeah i agreed
with the
the need to work on the bill um i think
it's an important issue
and uh um for the most obvious reason
that all of us were uh
born from pregnant mothers uh and in
this day and age a lot of women are
are still working out of uh necessity
and um we went over a lot of different
issues during the public hearing
um and opened up a whole can of worms so
i i think for that reason we need to
put some more time into this
wrong button again um i have to say that
um
i really feel this is ready to pass this
bill has been worked on for
years um and it is affecting
um both businesses and pregnant women
and it's time to to get this codified
um i think it was very clear in all
testimony
we had let's see 91 in support
of this bill of the many people that
that
testified that the human rights
commission works with the business in a
collaborative
way to be able to help when an
accommodation is necessary
nothing has rammed down any businesses
throats
um there's no encouragement to go to
court over it
and i think it's ready to pass um it's
been passed in the past in the past we
lost it last year but um i'm i'm gonna
vote against retention
because i would like to see it pass now
thank you mr chair i i definitely do
agree uh as i look over the list of
sponsors from the senate and and from
the house both
i i think we see a bipartisan overview
of of points of view uh as
representative breitling mentioned
there's a long history of this bill it
has been
moved and changed and beaten and was
ready to come forward
it is a bill that because of workforce
issues and because there are 51 percent
uh of females in in our in our in our
world
uh it's a pro-business bill it allows
women to remain in the workforce and and
to be productive in the workforce
but it's also pro-family and that it
helps to to foster
um healthy healthy pregnancies and and
to help foster healthy relationships
we all have mothers we all had mothers
at least we all have sisters and
aunts and uncles and and other
phenomenal uh caregivers who are
very capable of being in the workforce
and also very capable of
of being good solid mothers and yet
we are we are not giving them a little
bit of help that
that might help them to to make those
rules stronger and better for them
uh as the bill states uh if it doesn't
work within the business for whatever
reason
i don't know if i can uh i don't know if
i can find it offhand
um the accommodation would oppose an
undo hardship on the operation of the
employer's business that has been taken
into consideration by the bill as well
this bill is ready to go forward i think
that holding on to it
will be a travesty to all women as well
as to businesses
and i hope that we will vote accordingly
uh okay representative greeson
now thank you mr chairman uh during the
testimony
uh the lady named sarah braffman
had testified that she was not actually
pleased with the wording of the bill
for a couple of reasons and recommended
a
an amendment to it and actually sent out
an email with a proposed language for an
amendment but i have not seen
where anybody has sponsored said
amendment and i thought someone was
going to
uh put put forward an amendment but she
had an issue with the wording of
physical
disability considering pregnancy as a
disability
and that's very dangerous i don't think
too many women want to i don't know i
don't want to speak for women god help
me if i do
but my understanding is is women did not
want to
have pregnancy considered a disability
that was my understanding of her
testimony
so the wording as it is in the present
language of the bill says
uh taking a a including
a a possibility of a leave of absence
for the period of temporary physical
disability resulting from pregnancy
and that was a language that she did not
like and others did not like
and so without there being some kind of
amendment to change that wording
i don't think this bill needs to pass as
written
her whether or not we adopt uh the
wording of her amendment or some other
wording
uh to me it it i don't like the language
either
thank you i'm gonna agree with uh
representative greeson
for the simple fact as a woman i find
this language offensive
i gonna tell you from my experience i've
had two children i've worked
my employers were more than confident
you know more than reasonably
um able to work with me i worked up
until the day i gave birth to both my
children
i chose to put my children in daycare
and worked i did take them to work with
me at times
i had more than ample time for multiple
you know for the different businesses i
have worked for
more than enough effort was given by
our employee my employers and
the fact that this is saying that i was
a disabled because i was pregnant is
absolutely horrifying as a woman and i'm
sorry i will
not be a part of any legislation that
tells me i'm
representative herbert um
not all pregnancies go perfectly
[Music]
and so in point of fact i just consider
this a
pro family bill and uh
we don't have a good track record in
this state in my opinion
in regard to that particular uh concept
so um as a result of that i'm
not going to vote for the motion
uh representing van houghton
thank you um respectfully this has gone
through the senate and has passed in the
senate
it has gone through every one of us in
this committee and no one has presented
that amendment
uh it doesn't appear that anyone has
that kind of interest to make that
amendment for one and for two
uh retention to make that change that
could have been changed prior to this
seems
as though it's counter-intuitive uh i
think it's time for us to take a look at
doing the right thing pro business pro
family for women in the workforce
uh and to move this forward thank you
representative terry yes thank you mr
chairman um
as i have pointed out to you in
conversations
that we've had recently a conversation
that we've had recently
as a relatively new member to this
particular issue
although not generally speaking new to
the issue of course
i am looking for good faith efforts uh
to be made to resolve
any remaining issues that pertain
to some of the concerns that have been
addressed today in any others
so that we can act favorably upon
have the opportunity to act favorably on
this legislation
um in the uh in the next year very
sensitive to issues of
discrimination and want to make sure
that
we not be perceived as being
discriminatory in in any way
and so i hope we can get this fixed and
very sorry um in terms of the um
the argument that um it's state you know
the belief that the
bill states that that pregnancy is a
temporary physical disability i read it
differently
i see it saying that that the way i
interpret it is sometimes when you're
pregnant
you do have a temporary disability
there's the case of a family member of
mine who was pregnant
and had to be bedridden for two months
um
in order to have a full term pregnancy
so i don't read it that way and i think
it's saying that there can be temporary
physical disability from pregnancy
childbirth or
other medical conditions so i read it i
read it very differently
thank you and representative meckler
uh thank you mr chairman um this
amendment came
under a lot of discussion um i'm aware
of that
and it was my initial thought that uh
maybe this was a good idea but i think
the wording of the amendment
would actually make the the bill more
contentious
and i think that's why nobody actually
brought this particular amendment
forward
so i i certainly think this bill is uh
is ready to pass
thank you okay
um seeing no more hands uh
this motion is to retain by
representative johnson
and the clerk will call the role
representative yes senator hospital
yes representative ahmed yes
representative
[Music]
yes so johnson
yes president of terry yes
sorry no pervert
no i think i skipped representative abel
representative fargo no representative
weston no representative bell you
no representative burroughs help
representative mcaleer no representative
hunts
yes ten to nine okay motion carries
uh there's it's on retain motion so
there's no minority report
uh senate bill 69 uh representative
johnson second by representative patusek
moves to retain senate bill 69
is there any discussion on the motion to
retain
representative bartlett thank you
um i i i just shake my head
i i don't understand the opposition to
passing this bill
um again these are bills that have been
vetted
they are bipartisan they are important
to the workforce they're important to
businesses
people to work together um to keep them
out of court
um if there is a an issue there are
there's the human rights commission
right there um available to to help
um with any kind of mediation when if it
were necessary
and i don't know why we want to retain
this and
and delay it again
so i'll be against the retention motion
thank you i i agree with my colleague
representative bartlett i think this
bill
is as friendly to business as any such
bill could possibly be
as written now um and
i also think that it is uh
pro-family um because it
helps um it helps individuals who
have given birth and who are are
employed
um and i i can't see any reason to delay
it so i
i certainly will vote against the motion
to retain and think it should go forward
as
representative thank you i i do believe
my two colleagues who've just spoken
have eloquently stated uh the case
just about everything that was said
about the prior bill can be said here
healthy babies are a healthy future a
healthy state i have no
understanding as to why we would not
want to do very easy types of things to
help to ensure
healthy babies healthy mothers and
business and workforce that can be
stronger and better for our state
so i urge my colleagues to think about
that as you vote
um again an anti-family vote
uh for a pro-family idea
i'd say it's unfortunate that we are
getting that reputation
so that's enough said
and represented fire um again i think
this is a pro family bill
i i i'm even appalled that we have to
legislate this this should be a given
and i don't understand what why
we would retain this and i don't think
that any of you have really
given me a good reason why we would
retain this
what is wrong with this bill
well my understanding is is that the
at the end of the day this is an
employer mandate and the idea is to how
do we
make it so it is something that the
employers
are willingly and happily using the
human rights commission as a facilitator
to get to
the right answer but i really like to
be mandated yes yes for the question
yes we wouldn't be having this
legislation if that happened john
so i think because we have not been
successful using those venues this is
important
for families today so i just
i i'm really surprised that that you
would stop this
that's all i can say i i'll have to say
to you uh even the federal law
um has problems um i have i've heard
from people who
are clearly under the federal law but
that the process is such that that that
they're not being accommodated
so the idea is if we're going to get to
the right answer for new hampshire
we want to get one that both parties are
going into it with
representative van houten you want to
you're you're muted so i'm not sure what
you're muted today my apologies um i
would just like to point out
and remind us that both this bill and
the previous bill
do have what we call the hardship
exemption so it's not quite a mandate
the hardship exemption allows any
employer to be exempted from the
subdivision if it would impose an undue
hardship to the employer's operations
so i don't see that it's quite as quite
a mandate it is just a legislation that
will
um foster better business relationships
between
uh employees and employers and again
it's it's pro family it's pro-business
aren't we better than to to limit
pro-business and pro-family legislation
again thank you very much and i hope you
consider these issues because
we we are not doing justice to to young
families and to workforce in new
hampshire and we've got to start to do
that
representative greeson thank you mr
chairman
during the testimony and even
asking stories of other people just on
the side to see how
how much of an impact this is or how
much
issues that they've had in speaking
specifically to women who have been
pregnant during working or
uh recently and what i have been able to
find and what i heard
in testimony was that most businesses
are already making these accommodations
without there being a law
uh in fact the greatest violator or
or the the greatest uh obstacles have
been the state of new hampshire itself
the
employees of the state of new hampshire
uh and so
when it came to uh private businesses
making accommodations they're already
being done as much as possible that's
already being done
i i would love to know how many
discrimination lawsuits or complaints or
whatever have actually been filed i'm
not saying there's not any at all
but i wonder how small that number
actually in reality is
because we certainly if it were a huge
issue would have come out in testimony
and the only complaint was against the
representative burroughs yeah i just say
quickly that
um just because just because uh they're
just because you're saying that we
haven't heard a lot of complaints
doesn't mean that
that there are problems for employees
particularly vulnerable people
who don't have a voice um you know low
low wage workers who don't don't feel
that they can
speak out for fear of losing their
employment
so um i think that right there is is
good uh seeing no more hands the motion
is to retain
representative yes
representative osborne he is
representative admin yes
representative abramson aye
representative
yes representative de palma yes
representative greeson yes
president johnson yes representative
terry
yes representative bartlett no
representative abel no wizard of herbert
no no
no representative bill you no
representative burroughs no
mclear
okay since the bill's uh retain bill
there will be no minority report
um all right next up senate bill 97
relative to health insurance and i
believe
i i have an amendment uh for the bills
that i'd like to take up first
yes yeah risk you just muted yourself
chris
on the last bill uh um as it stands now
okay there's a good place to make an
okay uh so then 97 okay here's my
amendment uh
and uh trying to find the amendment was
it distributed
to us it was sent out by pan well no
this one
uh well this one i have asked a less
uh i do not see it i got it from yes
pam sent it out okay on may 11th
oh under amendments yeah search pam and
yeah i did okay so what
uh even though it's restating the whole
pharmacy piece
and the bill um it all it really did was
remove section one of the bill
so uh and section one as you right
recall that was the direct care
and which had was extremely problematic
so rather than
trying to fix that we want the pharmacy
so so representative hun second
representative patousik moves out to
pass on the amendment 14.
one any discussion on the amendment
okay see none the clerk will call the
roll
representative yes representative oswald
yes representative yes representative
abramson
aye yes
representative de palma representative
greeson yes representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bartlett yes
yes representative yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston
yes representative bellew
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt yes 19-0
okay uh
so uh representative uh de palma
seconded by representative whosex moves
uh ought to pass as
amended is there any discussion on the
motion yes representative
abramson you have a question you want to
speak
you need yeah you need to you need to
is that working yes uh so my question is
um what the original intent of the bill
i've got the amendment from me i don't
have the original bill
um so what what were they trying to uh
prevent
uh this is just a process uh
for the the pharmaceutical uh pharmacies
and um in terms of how the these
drugs are uh are the retail form
that's being used and um it was to
allow for mail order uh and to do that
okay i'm looking at the amended bill
again and i'm not seeing that it just
looks like a prohibition
uh uh okay
um in terms of
um this is a uh as a as related to the
network manager the problem the pharmacy
benefit managers
uh but that it it does allow the
pharmacies to
yeah representative bartlett thank you
mr chair
my notes here say that um taylor brennan
um testified on part two and he thinks
it's um
it's fairly complicated he think he
questioned whether
this would be increasing the costs on it
and i don't think this is ready
to be um to be passed um i
would be opposing the otp um
motion
well i mean i i didn't nobody had any
opposition
to it but um well we could we could
certainly retain it i'm i'm not
i don't i wouldn't yeah the new uh new
hampshire
independent pharmacies also had um
problems with part two
um they pre they it says stops retail
pharmacies from mailing to a patient
willing to
and even if they the pharmacists were
willing to pay a fee
um the pbms could say the pharmacy would
not get reimbursed for the prescription
the new hampshire insurance department
wants to add some other amendment
um and they were hoping the part two
would be separated from part one but
part two still had issues
so i i can't okay i thought rick newman
said he was okay
uh i can see retaining this one but i
can't see passing it so that was
that was prior to the bill that's being
spent but i can read to you
what rick newman wrote me mr chairman i
see senate bill 57 is scheduled for an
exec session
i'm aware that part one of the bill was
quite a lot of controversy however part
two dealing with allowing
retail pharmacies to use mail to device
uh to device prescription
i believe has no opposition
i represent the new hampshire
independent pharmacy association
and they support part two all
stakeholders reach agreement on language
when this issue is in senate
can we get this section passed happy to
discuss you with your convenience
okay well that's correct that corrects
what i've got in here
okay so that i i've always been on the
assumption that that
that part was okay okay sorry
so uh remember fargo does he work with
tyler perry because i too had notes that
uh that um tyler had some
recommendations for an amendment to
purchase
uh i i i don't see a problem with
retaining this and getting some clarity
from him since
he does the regulations and i think i
think that's important well
i mean i what i would probably do is
not retain it and that at this moment
that i'll just call another exact
session
and and then and then in the meantime
we'll get this sorted out
all right i think it's just great to
hear what tyler has to say yeah
my notes do show that he has some
question about it okay well
uh i do have hands up over here if we
want
uh see uh tyler i will allow tyler since
he's the stan employee
i will uh oh tyler did you just put your
tyler just disappeared are you still
there tyler
oh there he is okay all right i'm going
to promote
him so tyler can tell us
okay good morning tyler good morning
hopefully you can hear me
um so thanks for that i apologize for
lowering the hand before you actually
saw me that you had the the only concern
we had is that the
change that it does it changes the pbm
section of the insurance statute but the
way pbm
is defined there it does not include
when an insurer owns its own pbm
and that pbm service is just that
insurer
so you would impose be imposing a
requirement just on the pbms that are
operating under that traditional model
so the only suggestion we had is if you
want the new requirement
to apply more broadly you'd also include
the same language
okay so you know so we'd have to pay
lift it and also put it in
in the other side no do we have anybody
i know anthem was talking about having
their own pbm has anybody actually done
that yet
uh yeah i think that's the direction um
i believe both harvard and cigna are now
i mean excuse me anthem insignia are
there and harvard is still using a pdm
that will
serve as multiple other carriers and
obviously the other small carriers will
continue to use those traditional pbms
so it's um you could potentially have a
different standard every time but
again it's a relatively small chain so
it's not a huge deal but
that being said i think if we hear from
the pharmacies that we're not
requiring um the new you know the new
prohibition uh more broadly that would
be the reason
i think it could create some confusion
still
okay uh representative fargo did you
have a question
excuse me weston i just want to say that
i do remember that discussion that um
tyler brennan just brought up but
there's also one other small error
in this amendment and that is that the
effective date says part two but i
believe this is only one part now
so effective data is part two when you
only have
when the when you're part one is the
bill part two is the effective date that
that's normal
process
um so i do have rick newman and curtis
berry
one of one of the people i'm sorry john
that's not what i'm talking about if you
look at the last line
this uh we took out part one
correct one doesn't exist anymore right
so therefore
in the new bill that we would be passing
the amendment part one now
is the was two of the old
bill so now that's part one and then
whereas in that bill uh the effective
date was part
three now the effective date is now part
two well it still doesn't make sense to
me but i'll take your word for it
i see what representative weston is
saying mr chairman
okay reference to part two in section
two should have been removed from the
amendment
okay all right so we'll let's get this
bill fixed
as long as we're working some more we'll
work we'll call i'll
call another sex session um and
i i don't know if it'll be next week
only because
today is thursday it might have to be
the last week it will probably have to
be
uh that to next tuesday a week two weeks
from yesterday um so everybody be aware
of that
okay we'll with the uh
the motion of my motion on the amendment
i withdraw
okay all right um question about process
yes so we passed amendment oh we did
pass the amendment okay
so the motion for representative de
palma uh uh
are you are you willing to withdraw your
emotion
yeah okay okay all right so and then
patoozick is willing to second and move
his second
okay so we will withdraw our motion uh
at the right now the pending question
uh is that it has been amended uh which
sounds like it might need to be further
amended
and uh at that point we will then uh
take up
um take up senate bill 97 in two weeks
or so
okay moving right along then senate bill
the financial assistance for businesses
of coven 19
uh representative ham second by
representative patusek
moves in expedient to legislate and and
representative him is recognized to
thank you thank you very much um
this bill uh offers um
funding assistance uh for
businesses that were started after
um the cutoff date the may
26th during covid
um in my mind um
in my mind it's less necessary now
uh and these businesses made a choice to
start
um given the covid they didn't
experience adverse effects
because they were a going concern and
covert came along and and made it
difficult for their business and
and their employees i'm one of those
i i didn't expect assistance i made my
decision
with the with the givens in place and so
i i suggest that it should be
inexpedient to legislate
hey uh representative yeah i don't agree
um i don't have my notes here but i seem
to remember some
uh business owners who um were
talking about how you just don't open up
a business one day
it takes three four years sometimes to
get all the funding and everything
you know the um everything in place
before you actually
open up so some of these businesses
started
not in operation but you know being
formed and money being spent two three
years ago
assistance
okay okay uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um yeah i'm um
looking at my notes here as as well i've
got one there's um a brewpub
um the investing took a year um
had to get through various uh
regulation and opened in september 2019.
they closed march 16th for the
governor's order
um they had not planned on takeout so
they had to really change their
business model to begin you know right
off the bat because six months into a
restaurant
is certainly you know they're not making
a profit at that point then there's
another
one um where we had testimony from
a man mr clark who owns two restaurants
in durham
um and it took him a while after months
of planning opened up in march and
immediately was shut down
so they aren't re they aren't eligible
for this financial assistance
um and i do think that you know we
we really need to consider these
businesses
so that they are eligible and there has
been one point
what two billion dollars more has been
um sent to new hampshire that will be
distributed over the next couple of
months
and i really think they should be able
to be eligible for it
so i think this bill is really important
well why wouldn't they be available
because this bill is saying that um
main street relief fund uh for
businesses established it after may 26
of 2019
and the may street fund is done it's
over
but there's more money that's come in
right so that will be
that will have to be have a new name but
it certainly wouldn't have the same
parameters
as the main street fund did which was
the day
but that was all based upon the closing
of may you know that may 19
and saying show us what your business
what you were doing in the year before
that
do you know for a fact that this new
around of money
will include these businesses so because
there's money still left over that has
not been distributed from the first
relief fund i know for a fact that the
ppp money that was just
which i guess they just ran out was
absolutely available to everybody
it wasn't limited to anybody right and
that the new funding that's coming
in the uh the legit they they
uh the committee has not disturbed
determined
exactly how that's going to be doled out
uh but that it certainly would not have
the same requirement
that that main street fund did right
because that main street fighter was an
emergency funding
at that moment and it was based upon
what your business did the year before
so if they were to do it again this year
they wouldn't take
take that model they would be picking up
a new model which is how to help
businesses to go
forward and that would be all businesses
and
certainly would not have that
requirement involved in it
so yes all new businesses all those
businesses who didn't get funding out of
that program
would certainly be eligible for any new
proposals that is going forward
so what if these businesses had to close
after six months
and they didn't have the financial
ability to reopen because they weren't
eligible for that first one
are you saying the second one will apply
to those businesses
i don't think that they they will make
that i mean in terms of that
circumstance i don't think this bill
would solve that problem either
yeah you've got to have some specific
funding
mechanism to say is okay you know we're
going to
uh fund businesses that close and reopen
now you have to remember if this was an
obscure situation
it was based simply on the fact that
how do they know how much money to help
you out with your business
if they didn't know how much money you
lost
because you were in business the year
before well insurance companies do
this all the time for a business income
loss
it's not easy but it certainly can be
done and
i think this is all the more reason why
the governor needs to be disclosing
where the money has been distributed
under his largesse this bill this all
this bill
is say we hope he will do something this
bill doesn't do anything
and it really sends a false message of
that saying that we are doing something
when when we're really not doing
anything and like i said
any the new money that's coming in will
be spent you know that they will not be
using that requirement that that
particular
you know mainstream program did have
because that was in the beginning of the
coven
crisis uh
next up representative abramson uh yeah
this is more of a question i mean
if it's if there had still been money in
this
in this fund specifically the main
street relief fund or at least by the
time this bill
uh gets signed were to be signed by the
governor
um for these businesses that that
began operation after may 26
2019 how could they have or would they
have any funds or revenue or is it even
possible for them to have any funds or
revenue
to qualify uh for this is
right i
maybe if anybody i'm not asking this as
a rhetorical question matt can ask
asking this is an actual question
is there any possible way that a
business that that's not even
operating could have revenues before may
26th
okay uh representative him did you want
to speak again
yes and that was part of my thought um i
i looked at it and there's no way i
could fill it out i had no
revenue i could not fill out an
application very accurately
i couldn't say what i was going to do or
not do
so i just feel that this late
in in the covid uh process that
that um it was a program based on
certain criteria and i just they made
a program would be good perhaps for
folks
um that uh struggled or didn't make it
but
to me it didn't seem like this was the
one and there were rules
and and if you came after that date well
representative herbert uh
yeah i'm inclined to vote um
with my colleagues across the aisle here
it's uh
it's very uh this is in such huge flux
making law at this point in time
when we really don't have as as you said
i think there's
one point something uh you know yada
yada yada yada
a bunch of zeroes that are coming into
new hampshire
uh more i just think that it's
it's not our business to be it would be
nice if we knew what the governor was
doing
but uh absent that i don't i'm very
uncomfortable passing legislation that
would uh
make decisions of this kind
yes um i
uh it as i as i read this
very short bill it does reference
eligibility for the main street relief
fund
but then it goes on to say that that
anyone
who was not eligible for that would be
available for federal relief and it's
it doesn't specify that it has to become
has to come from that program
it just says that you you can be
eligible for further relief
through any program as long as it comes
through from the federal government
so i think that we should in fact go
forward
with this as a statement of what the
legislative
legislatures at uh intent
is and that it would make it would make
a big difference
[Music]
if this were passed so i urge us to pass
it
and represent bullio you've spoken
already
no um do we know that they're
about the status of the main street
relief
fund is there like no more money in the
fund do we know that for sure
yes that was that was a short that was a
it was a short plan
short program and is the fun
still available i mean not the funds but
is that mechanism still available do we
know
no because if the federal money comes
back comes in
to the state he might that he might put
it in the main street relief fund
and call it that i have full confidence
that the governor
heard about the problem and what
happened and we'll make sure that
that those businesses will not be
negatively affected he doesn't need this
legislation to tell him
uh representative abramson yeah i'm
i'm still trying to figure out if
there's any possible theoretical way
that this could do something
the bill says to the extent permitted by
federal law federal refunds received by
the state of new hampshire to assist
businesses affected by the coved 19
pandemic
shelby made a fit available to
businesses that were not eligible for
grants from the main street relief fund
because their businesses were
established
i mean it just does the bill do it
does the bill do anything that the
governor can't do already right now
no
okay uh everybody
the motion is an awesome question it's
not a
it's not a rhetorical question i'm
asking if there are any of the
supporters of the bill who
uh when we uh if if someone wants his
okay so representative
would you like to answer him
okay no i have something separate okay
so just so you understand uh
representative abrams and you know you
you you might not meant it to be a
rhetorical question you wanted an answer
but that doesn't mean anybody has to
answer you
so yeah representative van halen um
i was just going to say we intend to
meet in two weeks anyway to consider
uh information on another bill is it
possible that we could get someone in to
clarify
the direction as we know it to be today
and to make a better judgment on the
basis of that information
he hasn't taken my word for it but um
you really want to
delay this bill okay i mean i i i mean
i i would i it would have to be you
to go out and find something okay
because i
i i you know i talked to
taylor and and he told me that you know
whatever new money's coming in it's
going to be whatever new rules whatever
new parameters
you know i know there's a bunch of
parameters because it's the money's
going
right through the state this new federal
money uh and
the feds have plenty of requirements as
it is but
to uh um whether there's any anything in
here where there's going to be
actual direct payments by this day
to businesses i i don't know if that's
the question you're asking
but um i if you'll have to go out and
find that answer but i mean i don't i
might my comment what i heard was who
knows you know
they're still trying to we through i
guess what the requirements are but
it was clear that this uh this bill was
about a an obscure event
that was set based purely on
how do we decide how much money to give
a business
and the only way we can do that is we
got to look at what their books were a
year prior
i'm just concerned that we could
potentially close doors to businesses
uh much like representative will you
were saying who did invest time and
energy and
and everything the problem i have with
that is if you're assuming that the
governor
when this bill showed up on his desk he
would veto it
and then say screw those people i'm
gonna um you know
i don't know i i can't it doesn't make
any sense to me
to build in the first place because
it was it was an obscure event it's
scary thing that happened and but then
you're and it's all about the governor
ordering the governor to do something
and the governor has to sign or veto the
bill
so i i just don't understand why
it's legislation in the first place
nice help personally but if if uh
if you want to wait but since we are
agreed to to take up another bill we can
we can wait another two weeks on this
bill
that's fine that would be good all right
so
uh represent him are you willing to
withdraw your motion
yes that would be good to get some more
answers absolutely since we're meeting
again anyway
okay and uh representation you're
willing to withdraw your second
okay all right john yes
would you be willing to reach out to
taylor to get a statement from him
on the basis of what he knows to be the
situation
i i could certainly uh he's kind of hard
to get hold of but
i'll be trying i will i will reach out
to see what i can get from him too
to clarify um
he doesn't like to he generally he
doesn't like to wait too much into
legislation and you know but if if you
could
um if you want to phrase the question
you want i will forward that question to
him
all right i'll check with you offline
after i have a chance to think about
this thank you
all right all right um
all right senate bill 124 the on the bus
insurance legislation uh
representative hunt seconded by
representative patusek moves
ought to pass is there any anybody
question this is four different items
they're all related to
allowing different industries to be able
to um and sell insurance products
without being
insurance agents and licensed agents so
uh representative abramson you have a
hand up
yep i just wanted to to re-bring up the
the same uh issue that i brought up
during the hearing public hearing
which is that uh i don't like omnibus
legislation
um out on the seacoast we did campaign
against
omnibus legislation where you put four
issues together it is a legitimate
um it's a legitimate question about
whether four different insurance bills
are germane
to the same subject and i felt that uh
we should vote
individually on the on these four bills
on the floor they're all four i think
are bipartisan
but i i i felt strongly after seeing
some of the comments
after uh the flurry of real omnibus
bills where they had 35 or 40 different
bills unrelated bills packed into one
of the the public comments when you had
unrelated bills that were
that were all put together into a single
omnibus bill that the public generally
didn't like that at all
and i didn't see that the senate was
saving us any time by
taking four bills that had four lsr
numbers they all had different sponsors
and co-sponsors
um and it it makes the the hearings very
very difficult
to do that so i i i feel like we need to
you know contact the senate or or
something and just say please don't
you know don't bundle bills together and
send it to uh to the house
would would you feel better if we took
if we
amended the bill or took the word
omnibus out of the title
no it's it they started as they started
in the senate as four separate bills
they are they they're arguably germane
they're all on insurance
agent issues um but i
i really felt like each of these bills
deserved a separate hearing it make
it makes the hearings much more
complicated and
you might have you may have a few
members of the house who support
say three of these bills and then oppose
one do they have to vote
no on the entire you know do they have
to vote no on four bills at the same
time
under our state constitution we vote on
each bill
as as an individual bill and coming to
the house this way
i i felt that it's uh you know we have
to do this on the budget obviously where
we vote on
you know lots of different items but i
didn't feel that this was right
okay uh representative
okay representative bartlett i'm um
fine with this bill i think that we did
have a chance
to talk about the issues um to get
questions answered
it's got good support and um i'm going
to vote to
um support the amendment i support the
motion to pass it okay i
i i mean uh there's really no opposition
to this bill and you know
and max if you want to vote against no
that's your you're entitled to doing
that
but um yeah i understand that we all
have
um our certain things that are important
to us so
all right so let's just go forward uh
with the ought to pass motion
any more discussion on how to pass on
senate bill 124
representative yes
representative
somebody say something yeah can you keep
interested i'm sorry
are you calling on me yes i'm voting no
representative him yes
representative de palma yes
representative recent yes
representative johnson yes
senator terry yes representative
bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative herbert yes
representative
alton yes was it a fargo
yes representative weston
yes representative bill you yes
representative burroughs yeah
representative
yes yes
so it's 18 to 1. uh all right
representative anderson do you have a
problem placing this on the consent
calendar
um if it goes to consent am i not able
to write a minority report on this
uh that is true so i might want to do
whatever
you want to okay and what would you what
would your minority
promotion be um
i don't think we have the ability to
amend it
um i wanted to say otpa but
the house clerk said that we need to do
otp you have to have the event
you would have it have to have an
amendment drawn up correct itl but i'll
i'll correct that in the uh
blurb okay so your uh abrasion's motion
okay
okay all right
senate bill 125.
uh my representative hunt and second by
representative patusik
moves uh the amendment
to one two five
does anybody have the the amendment
number handy 12 37
h 12 37 8 is correct
and uh we did have a hearing so i think
pretty much everybody
we've kind of thrashed through this um
so
i think it's pretty straightforward but
i i think it's a it's a
it's a good step in getting um you know
the uh helping the the uh
brewers and beer manufacturers and uh
and there's a little bit of something in
here for everybody so i think it's a
it's worthy to be passed so any other
discussion on the motion about to pass
saying none the clerk will call the
wrong
representative yes
representative osborne is representative
yes representative abramson
aye representative ham yes
so it's palmer yes representative
greeson
yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes representative abel yes
yes representative fargo yes
representative weston yes representative
bellew
yes representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer yes
representative hans
yes team zero okay
uh representative huns seconded by
representative patrick moos ought to
pass on the amendment
and representative inhalton
okay
is there any discussion on the motion
about to pass as amended
see none the clerk will call the roll
wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh we do have a
question representing that
i'm sorry i missed cued on that last
item and i apologize for that
um i did vote for the amendment
um for the most part i believe that
amendments do clarify and and
make better the underlying bill however
with the addition of the amendment
we end up with what's essentially an
omnibus bill you've heard me speak
at least three times about the
three-tier system and the erosion of the
3ts tier system
uh i see this bill as part of a big
jenga game that that
structural wooden game that we pull
pieces out hopefully
not knocking over the structure i think
there's so much here
uh that it isn't whether the the
three-tier system should or should not
exist
this is something that will erode it
without being able to fix it
i i found it very interesting that um
representative abramson and i agreed
very definitely
that this kind of bill is something that
should go through a subcommittee
uh john you've committed to having
subcommittees the liquor subcommittee
might be a place to vet this type of
thing maybe
teasing out pieces or whatever the case
might be even ahead
ad hoc committee during the summer a
group of people who care about
what's going on with the liquor
commission i think we just have a whole
lot going on here i think that
we've mixed in direct shipping i was
looking over kate fry's email
as as you know i do kind of review my my
bills both the night before it and then
the morning afterward
and she asked some good questions about
uh maybe we should clarify training for
age verification and for
over service of young people prohibiting
delivery to college addresses
there's just so much going on here as
you know i've worked on liquor bills for
four years i was on the subcommittee as
chair last time
so i am sensitive to some of the issues
here and i am really sensitive to small
business i worked with representative
patusik on some tourism
related to uh to alcohol bills it is
just such a major big
ball of wax that we would be doing
justice to everybody all the way around
to retain this bill
and to work on it to really work on it
and maybe as we're working on it to take
a good look at the three chair system
i'm not saying whether it belongs or
doesn't belong it's a skeleton that has
been
uh fleshed out in a variety of ways
since after prohibition is my
understanding
and uh i i do think that we would all be
benefited
by slowing down on this one this is just
way too much
i do and i appreciate that you had the
separate hearing on it by the way i
think that that was very helpful
but that just elucidated the problem
this so much is going on
that um we we need we need to slow this
one down we really need to
i i believe we need to vote to retain
and therefore i will be voting
against the otpa and hopefully to
present a retain
okay uh representative fargo
um yeah i have to agree with connie on
this i i really do think we should
retain this i think there's a lot
a lot here i i think um even after the
audit
of the liquor commission and the
potential changes that might be
happening there
um you know we've spent a lot of time on
liquor over the last
um couple of years and i i just think it
needs a little
a little bit more discussion um so i i
support connie's idea
of retaining this and either having
subcommittee take it over or something
like that
and see if we can move it forward after
that
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair
you know it it's funny that even even um
the lobbyist um henry veyu
had to talk to you and me and
to others on our committee um over the
past week because of
some of the confusion over the
restaurant and lodgings
position over the past month or two
um and i think that certainly there have
been a number of questions that have
come up
on this one um even among the lobbyists
and
how they presented to us i know that
the last position that the restaurant
and lodging
association has is that they're now
neutral on it where they had been
pretty opposed to it in the beginning um
i think that there there is validity in
retaining this
um yes i think the amendment made it a
better bill
but i i have to agree that there's an
awful lot
to consider as we continue to
pass bills that are eroding the
three-tier system
so i will vote against the otpa
okay representative patousek thank you
mr chairman
uh as somebody who's been fairly
intimately involved with this bill
also uh and the manufacturers
and uh the brew the nanos and the
brewpub people
all are positive as to what they can do
and this will result in more revenue for
them and help the small businesses in
the state of new hampshire
i'm going to vote to otpa this
and moving on so that these
small businesses this summer will have
the opportunity
uh represent van houden you wanted to
speak again
yes this time i do thank you um and i
agree with representative patusik
i support small business i support these
these young startup
uh businesses that we're looking at but
i think it's incumbent upon us to get
the legislation right
we are in a bit of a sweet spot right
now we have the audit and
and some of the changes that have
happened to some of the changes that may
happen
we have lots of legislation happening we
have some lessons coming out of the
colbit pandemic that relate to liquor
and liquor
uh liquor procedures going forward i
think it's a really good time it's
a sweet spot for us to sit back take a
look at this um
get a subcommittee with even if it's an
ad hoc committee
i see the issues as being bipartisan
i've worked very well across the aisle
with
with people on these issues uh and and
some of us have had similar
sentiments regardless of party it's not
a party issue
it's a it's an issue of getting this
right the economic backbone that is
provided by the liquor commission and by
the liquor sales
is well worth getting it right and i
just think we have a
a doorstop we can finally say hey look
if we take a few months we can make this
better
and i hope we would consider that i
would like to vote to
to retain uh after the otpa is
spelled thank you okay
so uh just i retaining something
is meaning that we can identify
something specific that we want to fix
or change or revisit um i haven't heard
anything that anything specific other
than this global
retaining and and and
frankly you know when it comes to new
futures
i mean as new futures mission is
to to if they had their druthers we
would be going the complete opposite we
would be cutting off licenses we would
be reducing the amount of people
you know they got access to alcohol
because that's their mission statement
so i'm not sure that's that's something
i'm going to hang my hat on and why i
should retain a bill
um and if they feel some of those issues
are important they
certainly i can find you as a sponsor
and you can sponsor those builds
this discussion about three tier and i
really want uh
you know make it clear to everyone the
three tier
is a theoretical concept okay
it in terms of how it it's built
and we will always
have the three tier we always because
each
the tiers are easily identifiable and
their
purposes and missions are identifiable
the
what we've been tearing down was the
three-tier created artificial
barriers inside each of those
those uh tears um that was at the time
was rationalized is that that maybe this
will help
the prohibition but um i think that
andrew klein's
uh letter editorial was right on the
money when it said was
no it was really just to protect those
three different indian
and and protect their little monopolies
and i don't think anybody wants to
promote
monopolies um the idea that we're going
to
um you know pause and see whether we
want to
revisit go back to monopoly or go back
to some three-tier
uh limitations i i that does not make
sense to me either
um so i i i caution everyone
in terms of what this bill is this is
you could say this was a
coven bill by the way because this was
uh
the senator when it was working with the
uh the the beer
the beverage manufacturers and saying
what can we do to help your industry
and some of these items were identified
in a report
that the liquor commission did um you
know it's going
on about six or seven eight years ago
and some of these items were in that
list
um so these are issues that are being
addressed the restaurant and hospitality
i mean
all due respect you know they're there
they were trying to protect
their tier was they didn't like the idea
they never liked the idea that beverage
manufacturers um
were selling beer and serving
beer right because in their minds on the
three tier
they're they're the only ones allowed to
serve beer okay
and because they they're the only ones
with the with the on-premise license and
nobody else
should be able to do it and that's
protectionist and that's monopoly
i mean you know not necessarily a good
idea but
we made the decision and i believe it
was uh you democrats who
it was you were in the majority of the
time that you give
a one winery that the idea that they
could have
one retail location and
um i personally you know point out
that's a violation of the three tier
but i was willing to go along with
because i think that it is appropriate
that once we made the decision then we
want to allow uh
liquor beverage manufacturers or wine or
whatever
to be able to have tasting rooms and
have the opportunity to give people to
get that product
you have to taste it and buy it from
those locations
that it might make sense that somebody
might
might be in the zoning with the
community doesn't think it's a good idea
that they have that parking and traffic
or whatever consumers coming in there
and that maybe it's better to have a
different location
uh for them to do that tasting room so
um i was willing to go along with one
and one is one um and i know that the
restaurant hospitality is concerned that
you know the
old camel's nose are in the tent and
once you have one then you know
what's to stop you from then going to
10. and uh
i can assure you that i have no
intention to vote
for more than one and and that's and
that was reassuring for them
and that's why their position and on the
bill has changed
but that they're still fearful of that
you know that someone
that would take away their special
privilege which is that they are the
only ones allowed to serve liquor
so um i can all i can ask is
is that if you can really show me
something in here
that really needs to be fixed or whether
i feel the bill was well worked over
we really fine-tuned it um and
and i think we've done a good product
and that's why i had another hearing
just to make sure we're all
you know okay with it so unless we can
really find issues that are blatantly a
problem that need to be fixed
um i i think retaining it is not a good
idea
so i'll let you have the last word honey
thank you
and i do defer to your ex your expertise
on this and we've worked
collegially together for years on liquor
bills
um the primary point that i'd like to
simply leave us with is the idea that
cut and paste
doesn't always give us a chance to look
at doing things better
taking a step back and looking we've got
a bill here with direct shipping in it
and we've got
samples that can be up to a quart
there's just a lot going on here and i
think there might be a lot of value here
but let's take a step back and let's not
just cut and paste the whole time let's
take a look and look at the
at the entire structure let's not play
the jenga game
uh try to see which you know which piece
will be pulled out and toppled and
structured
that's my request thank you well i i
certainly would give the charge to the
blicker subcommittee
to spend some time and and try to
identify
how they would try to rewrite the liquor
statute
in a way that uh that works better but i
i'm telling you
i attempted that a couple of times but i
had my head handed to him but
i would say at this point um it is uh
as byzantine as it looks um it is it's
an awkward situation but
um it's you know it's this and zoning
are the only mother may i laws that we
have so
it's kind of the nature of the beast so
okay uh having no more hands up will the
the motion
is uh ought to pass
um as amended is the question clear
the clerk will call the roll
representative yes
president of osmore yes representative m
yeah your voice went out for a second
representative de palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes instead of terry yes
representative abel no
representative van haltman no
representative fargo no representative
weston
no representative bill you
no representative burroughs
yes i think you missed me
representative yes okay i made the note
uh representative uh who did i call last
value
yes representative
yes
retained no
mr chairman i don't think you can use
that motion okay
mr chairman ito okay
yes representative terry uh thank you mr
chairman could we have the uh
the clerk please read back the the the
role and the uh the votes that were
recorded
charlotte i agree you know
elimination right that doesn't sound
right mr chairman
doesn't sound right either to me at 13
13 to five yeah
all right uh should we just call it
again or do you want me to read it
uh what you go down the list and
or i don't know how because you're doing
okay don't we need to get to 19 we
we were we're at 19 with 11 to 8 but i
believe
that uh representative herbert and
representative burroughs and
representative mcaleer
and representative phillip fellow uh
bella
so this needs to be done again yeah
polio did vote no
no she voted yes i voted yes but i
wanted to vote no
hey maybe this would be dangerous
all right so why don't we go through the
roll call one more time
yes representative osmond yes
yes yes
senator griesen yes representative
johnson
yes representative terry
yes representative bartlett no
representative abel now
representative herbert yes
representative van halton
no what was in fargo no
representative weston no representative
bell you
no representative burroughs yes
representative mclean yes
representative hans yes 14.
the last two on the democrat side
this uh placed someone's 13 to 6.
thank you for catching this okay 14 to 6
13 15 years
13 6 13 to 6. all right
there we go and representative will have
have a
minority report with an itl yeah
thank you all right last but not least
uh senate bill 138 uh relative to
investment medal
contracts representative ammon seconded
by representative petusa
uh moves out to pass
represent him do you want to speak to
your motion
where is he i'm here i'm catching up i
have uh
that don't cooperate all the time so one
second
all right so this is senate bill uh 138
investment medal contracts so i move on
to pass on this
this brings uh investing in commodities
such as precious metals and
other other uh items of value
into the 21st century
it changes the definition of
uh it actually adds a definition
that allows commodities to be uh instead
of the person
receiving them so instead of ordering
let's say gold or silver online and
having to receive it
physically to your residence or
someplace that you control
this allows for a delivery to be made to
a depository
storage facility that's licensed and
regulated
and that'll count as the purchaser
having received it as physical delivery
um we had some testimony uh
on behalf of this bill that this is
common practice in other states
and that we need to update new
hampshire's laws to allow this
if you have a significant amount of gold
or silver
in your physical residence you're at
risk that someone might
break in and seal it from you you have
to provide your own
security by allowing it to be delivered
to a physical
depository who does that for uh you know
as a business model they have increased
security
and uh that takes some of the risk off
of uh citizens that are engaged in this
so uh with all those reasons i move all
the best on
my question is you you mentioned silver
and gold
for representative ammon for the sponsor
bill
uh representative herbert uh and uh
you know the answer is uh it talks about
investment gems investment medals
it's all in the uh in the bill itself
right
so if it's an investment type metal
i mean i'm pretty sure people don't
choose aluminum as an investment metal
where you can do platinum but platinum
would definitely be in
platinum gold and you know anything that
you know
yeah and and then also when they talked
about the gems
definitely had a feeling that this was
kind of metals that would be used for
jewelry
yeah so another question
for the question questions to get my
mind clear this
um so in effect this is an operational
type of
legislation that allows
i'm familiar with stocks and bonds but
somebody else is holding the paper
right so this allows storage storage to
be done
uh sort of automatically at a place that
you do business with
correct and but out of state in order
that
if it wasn't an in-state problem it was
an out-of-state problem
that so if you're if you're if you're
buying a
chunk of metal and it's in california
it doesn't make sense to ship it in new
hampshire just to
have it for a period of time until you
decide what you're going to do with it
so that you can leave it there in
california okay thank you
okay uh representative abramson
can you hear me yes we can um
so i'm looking at the text for sb 138
and the website
says that this is uh relative to
consumer protections against
profiteering and necessity so i support
one bill and not the other
so when i talk to legislative services
and and there's been a
a difference between one version of a
bill and another they go by what's on
the website
and what's on the website is is this
bill by
uh senator sherman um
and it's it's the one saying you
couldn't uh
increase prices and there were some
structural problems with that bill so
i'm wondering um if we're voting on 130
sb
138 which is what you're looking at was
the underlying the original underlying
bill
um in advertising it says as
introduced but what we're looking at is
this
okay i don't i don't have the text of
that
i was able to bring it up off the gen
court website go to gen court type in
sb 138 and then i pulled up the pdf
version
and i have it from yeah if i if if i
yeah i'm not sure how you're searching
you know but yeah
when i because i always go to the
committee and i see bills
okay uh representative mclaren um just
to
uh maybe uh talk to uh
mr herbert uh representative herbert
this is really exactly like if you had a
at a stock bond account at merrill lynch
or any other
uh you you probably wouldn't take
receipt of the stocks
in this case it's a little bit um
very similar and the reason you don't
want to take receipt
is if you have these precious metals in
an ira
account or a 401k account and if you
took
receipt of them you put yourself in a
taxable position so you don't want that
so it's convenient for for somebody
investing
just with not qualified money but it's
an absolute mandate
for folks that are investing with
qualified money you don't want to take
constructive receipt
because you'd have to pay taxes on thank
you
interesting okay
oops
yes johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative bart yes representative
abel
yes representative herbert
yes representative van gaalton
representative fargo yes representative
weston
yes representative bill you yes
representative burrows yes
representative mclean
yes and representative tom
yes 19-0
okay uh all those in favor of placing
138 on the consent calendar please say
aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay all right so we have two of these
two bills left
uh and uh i will schedule uh
something um uh
for uh in two weeks and
um i i did get
i got a uh text from uh henry
um and it's about the governor's ruling
so
uh there might be another bill here that
that we might have to
check the effective date on because of
the governor's uh
ruling of ending the uh
the coven emergency order so um
stay tuned on that one um other than
that
um i'll see you all in a couple weeks
mr chairman real quick uh give you a
heads up the grafton county executive
committee is meeting
on uh monday the 24th so if you can
not schedule this for that day all right
get back together on that day that'd be
great
go for the tuesday the 20th uh that
meeting's not till four o'clock though
we usually are done by then
and i think rockingham counties meeting
on friday
mondays and fridays i try to enjoy void
session
session day exact sessions on mondays
and fridays so
okay so what i'm going to aim for
tuesday the 25th
so all right uh
the chair rules that we are adjourned
i